but if someone walked through this door
and offered me 50 million possessed
right now I wouldn't take it and it
wouldn't it wouldn't scratch the sides
um I gen I genuinely believe that
whereas actually when I sat with you
before I don't think I would have said
that Callum ly the founder of AD some
zest after 8 years of working for
somebody else becoming an MD at just 24
years old and successfully scaling the
business to 20 plus people in October
2022 he decided to launch his very own
recruitment business there's a funny
thing in recuitment where people try and
be a bigger business than they are yeah
where we're this huge business what's
the advantage of that in the first year
of trading they did just over 500k is
worth of Revenue they achieved a plus 89
MPS score 100% fill rate and grew the
team to five so how did he do it first
thing on my TV when I went into my first
job do do a TED Talk and make two people
millionaires over night the only thing I
think that's changed in that I want to
make more people millionaires overnight
this is what you're going to learn in
this week's episode The power of
productizing your service and how to do
it how he achieved a 100% Bill rate why
Callum says no to working with more
clients and he does say yes why is
Callum so passionate about measuring
custom experience and why you should be
too let's get into this week's episode
Callum welcome to the podcast good to be
here good to be here good to be back
yeah for sure I mean uh we last sat down
three years ago was it three years three
years I was listening back to it
I should have listened before before
coming back on but no it's uh I'm I'm
back with far less hair than I had last
time that's all I know obviously we've
known each other for a little while now
be fair yeah so we're here today to talk
about this entrepreneurial Journey that
you started which is uh your own
recruitment business called Adam zest
yeah and when we lost sat down you was a
young director of a business that you
helped scale to like 20 plus people yeah
and you've now kickstarted this this
business Journey so in this conversation
I'm really excited to break down these
first 12 13 months because you you've
hit that first year Milestone yeah yeah
yeah you often hear first year in
recruitment is hard starting your own
recruitment business first year is also
really hard so couple of things
obviously when we prepared for this
couple of things I think just to give
people some immediate context so before
you started your own recruitment
business I think we put down here you
had like 10 years of experience yeah
just Just sh I have 10 years so nine
years of experience seven of that was
leadership and not Billing at all yeah
cuz when we sat down I think I remember
you saying you was like or you became
director like 24 or you was in a quite
senior position quite young right yeah
and it was an odd Journey so like so
like now going back to doing something
from the ground up it's something I've
never done before so so a couple of
things I know you're um proud of but in
this year like we're going to talk a lot
about this but you you uh finished with
a plus 89 MPS score and talk a lot about
that customer experience I know that's a
huge passion of yours you're able to be
profitable month for month which is
something to be really proud of um I
think you just broke the 500k Revenue
Mark for the first year uh I think we're
going to talk about this but in the
first five weeks you able to retain your
first free customers yeah that's
definitely something to be proud of cuz
I know when we were chatting you was
like I'm going to get back on the tools
and haven't properly been on the tools
for a while so I think that's absolutely
awesome and uh you're now so how many of
you are there now in the team there's
five of us now so yeah so first year I
think Kudos sir yeah no no sir and I
wasn't expecting if I'm honest when I
launched the business in October and
left the previous business in July for
the market to kind of completely
completely crash so I think it's been
the best um best 12 months to kick
things off um and yeah I'm really
pleased with where we've got to and the
team we've managed to put together so
just give us a bit of context on so all
of the type of recruitment that you do
is has been permed this year right so
all perm um 90% is UK a bit across a Mia
but everything kind of commercial within
Tech so sales marketing operations
within any sort of Technology business
mainly software so let let's just start
with just have a bit of a reflection
point on we've hit the 12- month marked
first year Milestone like what I know
you've done a couple of posts on this
but if I was to say to you what was your
biggest lesson from that first year what
what would you say let's just start
there it's really biggest lesson it's a
really good question but there's there's
so many lessons that I've learned it
being completely my own business um I
think in some ways it's been harder than
I imagined especially considering the
the market but I think the biggest
lesson that I've learned this year but
throughout every element of my
recruitment experience is if you have
the right team and you put the right
people together and you collaborate
efficiently and effectively anything is
possible like that that is that is the
most important thing within recruitment
to me people talk about it being your
own business within a business and it
being so quite like a selfish and
Standalone job but I don't necessarily
agree with that I think the right people
in the right
places the right collaboration and
anything is possible so that that's kind
of been my biggest or is it's just
backed up that belief this year but it's
certainly harder than I think I thought
it would be in some
senses and I feel like when you go out
on your own
those the relationship ship and the
people that you believe you have I guess
yeah good relationships with I feel like
is really shown cuz I've seen you post
multiple times just being really
grateful for all the people that have
helped you along the way and I think
that's always something interesting you
experience is when you go out on your
own you really do see uh a lot of people
come out of the Woodworks or people that
you might built relationships with but
you're really not sure exactly you know
how strong relationship is but uh it
sounds like you've had a lot of people
just help you on this journey as well
which I'm sure have been so many
relationships you built over time which
is quite cool to experience as well well
I I have I stupidly didn't listen to the
episode that we did however many years
ago but I I remember seeing the caption
of that not too long ago and it was
focus on relationships over money and uh
I've always had that philosophy I've
never burnt a bridge with anyone um and
whether it's an internal stakeholder so
an employee whether it's a customer
whether it's someone that we can't do
business with um for whatever reason
just never burn a bridge and you'd be
surprised
how many people will help and how many
people will be there to support and and
we all had non-competes we all had
covenants starting an ethical
recruitment business um you don't want
to kind of You Want To Tread on the the
right side of all of that
so it's difficult generating 100% new
business but I tell you if you have the
right people in the right places and you
do right by people it's yeah it's hard
but so many joyous kind of moments and
experiences is on the way where people
have kind of given you a leg up and
tried to help I think one of the things
that I saw you right about which I
really resonated with and it's something
I've been thinking about recently is I
think you it was one it was one of your
posts around listing some of the it was
like 12 months from leaving my uh High
paay job to go out on your own one of
the bullet points you put on there was
the the growth opportunity that you get
by starting your own business and and
that's something that really resonated
with me which I think sometimes s people
maybe underestimate or don't think about
that by going on this entrepreneurial
Journey the personal development and the
self-development like Journey you have
to go on it sort of accelerates that
doesn't it like you being on your own it
really just accelerates that
self-development because you have to
evolve you have to grow and you're in so
many situations which you're in for the
first time that you have to learn to you
know you're someone that really wants to
yeah do more for yourself maximize your
own potential going on this
entrepreneurial Journey can be a real
Catalyst for that it's not easy
absolutely yeah yeah there's there's so
many I remember I don't know if I
mentioned it on our last episode but one
of the first things I ever did and the
first kind of year and a half that I was
billing before I kind of went into this
odd early position of of management and
leading a team was try and it's a weird
thing to say try and do five things a
day ideally before lunchtime that make
me anxious like those those hard
decisions those really whether it's
giving the feedback you don't really
want to give whether it's um pop
knocking on someone's door a new
business um opportunity whatever that
looks like and I think in in a funny way
like starting your own business forces
you to make all these really hard
decisions and there's there's no other
way it's it's only before I had a team
of 25 people that I could lean on
collaborate with bash heads together
with for the first three months it was
only me and then there was only three of
us so kind of going from not billing
from for seven years back to that being
the only way to survive but also the so
many many opportunities to kind of FR in
those decisions and in those experiences
it's always looking for the the hard
things that you can do and and again
there there'll be so many joyous moments
out of that so let we're talking a bit
about here looking back so I want to go
into how you've built this business over
the last 12 months but just to remind
you I know you didn't listen listen to
it maybe I should have to listen it but
the only thing I want to bring up I
thought I'm going to put you on the spot
here but I thought let me just bring it
up and and see um
if you've achieved any of these things
so you said when we were talking three
years ago you were just talking about
the importance of having a why so that
still Rings true today and something
you've always been an advocate for in
terms of understanding your employees
why so they have a real driver and you
said it when we sat down your why was to
do do you remember what it was to do a
TED talk to do a TED Talk make two
people a millionaires overnight have you
gotten with that not yet but it's
happening yeah no it's uh yeah no that's
the first thing on my CV when I went
into my first job do do a t talk and
make two people millionaires overnight
the only thing I think that's changed in
that I want to make more people
millionaires overnight but I'm probably
less focused in making myself money the
evolution
from kind of I don't know going into
recruit I'm so so so so so lucky for
what recruitment's given me it kind of
I've earned more money than I ever
thought I would earn I've
bought well i' I've got everything that
you think you want and and that's that's
what that's kind of the decision that I
found myself in in starting zest I was
earning a incredibly good salary had a
team of people who trusted me implicitly
were incredibly bought into kind of the
vision and and what we wanted to
do and and I I had every I bought bought
a house nice car all these lovely things
but there was something missing um and I
think turning 30 was quite like a
pivotal moment and I just
thought I could keep going I could earn
a very good amount of money I could live
a lovely life but I I wouldn't I
wouldn't make the impact on the world
that I wanted to make it wasn't
purposeful enough it wasn't impactful
enough and that's what really sort of
started this sess journey and in if
anything I'm not going to say I'm I'm
I'm a I'm a recruiter I've been
ridiculously fortunate and I'm a
ridiculously fortunate position to say
this but kind of the more money I earn
the less happy I was and um the goal is
still to to scale zest um but if someone
walked through this door and offered me
50 million possessed right now I
wouldn't take it and it wouldn't it
wouldn't scratch the sides um I gen I
genuinely believe that whereas actually
when I sat with you before I don't think
I would have said that so it's it's it's
slight maybe slightly different approach
but the same the same principles
definitely still sting true so what what
I really enjoyed learning
about this the way that you've
approached your business is a lot of
people I sit down with a lot of
recruitment Founders and often times
what you hear is they they want to do
things differently but I think there's
the best way to really showcase you're
doing things differently is by actually
showing with actions right so this is
some of the things that I really want to
break down with you which I think you've
done a really good job of of actually
being different and enabling you to to
gain good Traction in the first year
particularly considering like you said
you haven't been on the tool selling for
for a good amount of time so of course
that why wouldn't you feel um a bit
daunted by that
tools am going be do it these things so
I I want us to come on to we're going to
talk about customer experience and why
that's been I feel like at the the
center of how you've approached things
but what I think you've done a really
good job of which I wanted to break down
is really you've productized your
services I feel like right um and I
think that's something that more and
more recruitment companies recruiters
should should be doing uh so I think
some of the the highlights here we we'll
break this down but I think in the first
year correct me if any of this is wrong
by the way I think you said 23 out of
the 25 customers that you work in the
first year all worked in a retain basis
yeah um and then um so that's
fundamental and then because of that
that's enable you to reinvest in in in
the business your job to fill ratio and
your field rates are much higher and I
think what would be really cool just to
break down how you've approached that
service cuz I think it' be really useful
for people and it also showcases how
you're what you're doing is different so
do you mind if we break that down a bit
right in terms of actual so what you
shared with me then is so how did you
initially frame this up was it did you
call it a retainer when you start speak
to customers like how do you it's an
it's an interesting one I we talk about
productizing our services if I'm honest
the first year we only really have one
service and it's retained um and I will
just say we don't do anything else um
partly
because we're incredibly fortunate and
the the goal is still to to to to sort
of carry on on this journey but to only
have experienced Consultants um I think
one of my bug Bears potentially around
kind of customer experience is a lot of
recruitment agencies have some really
like just experienced successful
credible charismatic directors who go
out and win retain business and then
might pass it to a graduate who's only
six months into the job to fill and
actually that's nothing to do with the
it's really unfair on the graduate but
the the the the customer experience for
that customer won't be great so I I kind
of just said we're only going to work
retained work we don't we don't even
call it retained it's just it's just our
model and what we do um this is how zest
works that's just how zest Works um and
if you can do it great if you can't
that's that's absolutely fine and I'm
I'm really hope there'll be an
opportunity for us to work together in
the future but for the moment because
because it's kind of like I I I feel
like most recruitment agencies will say
they do something and then when someone
says no
we can't he can't do that they'll change
it it's like being working in Louis
Vuitton someone comes in and asks for a
bag and they ask for five I don't know
how much LU on bag is, b, and they say I
don't have, p and they're like okay $800
that never happens like if you're proud
about your service if you're proud about
what you offer we charge we charge what
we charge do you have to say no to a lot
of people we say we say no still to far
more businesses than we say yes to and
it's a hard thing to do but it's uh I
think it's a really thing to do and You'
be surprised when you say no how many
people want to work with you just
curious bitball in here but I I really I
really respect that and then that shows
in your customer experience the roles
that you win like the the FI ratios then
that means your team are going to be
paid more often Like You can predict
like the future a lot more you can have
more consistent performances how many
clients do you reckon you say no to to
get one yes about one in five so so so
we will out of those 25 customers we'll
probably have spoken to maybe just over
a hundred I think and we've only worked
with 25 said this is how we work and
they said look Callum could look we
don't really work we haven't worked this
way with other companies can you work
this way there's been the two clients
that we that we worked with out so those
20 25 customers 23 were retained the two
clients that we worked with outside of
that agreement um one of which spent
over six figures with us and they just
couldn't they couldn't get it signed off
but they absolutely it was someone that
I knew through someone I could qualify
out really um thoroughly and had a
really good assurance that it was 100%
exclusive and we were going to fill fill
the role um and we we continued to go on
to to to fill over 10 business
development directors for that business
um but everyone else just say if if you
can't do it that's that's absolutely
fine but that that this is the way that
we work and we can prove if you do if
you do um sort of move forward or you
can get the sign off and you can try
something different that you can that
you can trust us because we've got a
plus 89 MPS score we've got every
customer that we've worked with we'
filled their role got 100% fill rate and
every customer that we've worked with
have given us a positive review so it's
it's again it's it's a joyous position
to be in but you don't need a huge
amount of customers in recruitment you
just need customers that want to go on
the same Journey as as you do and
that feel that they want a true partner
and that that's what we are if if you
want a contingent recruiter there are so
many other options and I'm sure so many
great options um that they can go to but
that's just not us I feel like you just
explained it there but I think it' be
helpful for people you said at the
beginning of this you don't like to burn
Bridges what what's callum's thoughts
and advice on saying no to business
about burning a bridge like what does
that what does that sound like you were
talking about it there but I think
that's interesting for people because I
think people underestimate how much
power there is in saying no but maybe
sometimes people they don't want to they
don't want to feel like the client they
put the client on the pedestal they
don't want them to feel rejected but how
how do you say no without burning a
bridge you can still add a huge amount
of value to a to a relationship there's
there's a whole host of and if you say
no you've got more time so what most
recruiters will do is out of those say
five companies and then they have 25
spending customers imagine how much time
and energy goes into working those 80
roles that they're probably going to
fill 20% of contingently so the amount
of time that you have you can still have
you can I I go for roughly three coffees
a day I'll meet so many people I'll give
a rediculous amount of value or or try
and help people wherever I possibly can
I'll try and offer free intros and and
and help anyone that I can but am I
going to put the time and resource into
a search unless they pay me up front or
pay us up front absolutely not and
exactly the same with our team so we're
a service first business so there's
there's there's of course ways that you
can politely and my background is
Hospitality we can go into that in a bit
more detail but you can politely um say
it's just not right it's Louis Vuitton
example if someone can afford it there's
nothing there's nothing wrong there's
plenty more bags that they can go and
buy it's just not right at the moment
but we really hope that you come back
back and one day byy Louis vitt back
yeah it happens it does does happen um
quite often and people people need to
experience a pain like unless someone's
our vision is to radically change the
perception of how a recruitment agency
serves its people customers and
communities and unless people have that
unless their perception is bad or
they've had a a crap experience with a
recruiter which most people have or a
bad hiring experience or someone who's
joined and then left early
on
there's there might not be enough of a
pain for them to trust us enough to pay
us a third up front and I'm very
conscious as well with our fees our
average fee is uh over 12 Grand to pay
4K to someone that you don't know from
Adam is is a big decision so again it's
making sure that we're very clear with
what we do very clear with the value it
brings and if someone can do use us
today great if they can't kill them with
kindness make sure you're adding value
make sure that you're you're continually
checking in and and trying to provide as
much value as you can
so that when when they have enough pain
or when they they they want to use us
we're the first people they think of
yeah and I want to go into what this
service looks like but I think people
might be thinking it because of what you
mentioned earlier starting on this
journey you said you have all this
evidence to point out to say look this
is how we work this is how it's work for
those companies but what what did you
have to point out when you first started
cuz that can often be a bit of a it's a
really good question back background um
reputation and
um people like referrals build building
Bridge like building relationships with
people and people think building a
relationship has to do with your CEO um
Sal senior sales director or whatever
the build relationships with everyone
just be a nice person just try and add
value and and I'll say add add some zest
to every interaction and that's what I'm
constantly trying to do whether it's
buying a coffee whether it's speaking to
a candidate of course exactly the same
philosophy a recruiter can't help every
candidate find a job but they can help
every candidate so they can add value to
that interaction can I help with your CV
can I actually have you thought about
this Avenue have you thought about that
you're still spending the same time with
that person but instead of being that
boring person who takes a list of
questions and does the qualification
just add value add value to the
conversation and the first the first
three customers I've never thought about
this were candidates who I would have
spoken to
when I first started and I've just kept
a relationship and actually LinkedIn is
a great tool to do that and I know
you're a big advocate of like kind of
personal brand but people they they feel
like they know you because even if I
haven't spoken to them popped up in
their LinkedIn inbox given them a call
they feel like they know you you it
sounds like you leveraged your track
record of just the journey You' been on
your experience you had and was you
upfront and honest of like did you was
they aware that they're probably going
to be the first couple of clients that
you're working with yeah and I and I I I
also I don't know you you'll have a much
better lens of this than I will there's
a funny thing in recruitment where
people try and be a bigger business than
they are perceived yeah well we're this
huge business what's the advantage of
that like I I I don't understand like us
I think people are worried about what
other people like how are they're going
to be perceived which is why I'm asking
you cuz at the start of that Journey but
it just sounds like you was honest you
obviously a lot of people that start
their own business often times they do
have a track record so you pointed at
that and then you got their searches
underway you obviously did everything
that you can to F them deliver a good
service and then you have evidence to
point that yeah recruitment is all about
time and resource and if you put enough
time and resource and you're you're
skilled enough and it's it's there's
still capability there but I was always
confident there's always that kind of
impostor syndrome insecurity of I
haven't build for seven years will I be
good enough but if you put enough time
and resource in and you update people
and you kill them with kindness and you
try and provide a bloody phenomenal
service people will be thrilled but yeah
it's funny so the first the first
customer who ended up spending over six
figures with us I put a post out on
LinkedIn saying I've just launched the
business give me a call put my mobile
number and I was surprised that no no
one tried to call me to sell me anything
um but yeah 11 people popped up in my
LinkedIn inbox saying we're a service
provider or whatever we can we can do
your it no one called me yeah an old
contact called me and said Callum I've
seen your post I thought I'd give you a
call we're recruiting for a business
development director can I intro you to
our to our sales director and it that
that business ended up spending over
over six figures with us so that's like
the perfect story in line what we're
talking about earlier not Burning
Bridges relationships so let's just
break down the service because I think
this is this is something that has been
key about how you've been able to to
grow and how you're going to be able to
continue to grow right and it's also at
the center of your mission around the
the customer experience
so you you tell me Parts if I miss any
of this so in terms of like this service
how it's broken down cuz I feel like not
everyone has the same perception of what
retained is some people just feel like
uh in order to initiate a search then uh
you know I have to put down a deposit or
it's just me paying for the commitment
of time and then we start working
together but you've built out a proper
process around this which I think is is
really great and I think is going to
give you uh and your team a competitive
advantage in in the marketplace for sure
so if you don't mind breaking this down
with us so if me and you were to start
working together in this way that you
were talking about so this s this is our
service then at the beginning of that
Journey we're going to have a uh job
qualification and that's going to be I'm
assuming a fairly Deep dive going to go
through everything yeah and then what
you're telling me I'll let you go
through it but what you're telling me
then is you're going to get a short list
of people but you do that in a slightly
different way and then after that you've
also invested in some tools to give me
as a hor manager more science-based
insights into what this person might be
like um and then there's some other
interview elements but why don't you
talk us through this cuz I feel like
this is something that you've obviously
thought about and is is a really nice
service that you've built uh which is
obviously delivering great results and
not just customer experience but actual
results of actually making these
placements as well yeah no no so um we
as part of our process so you're you're
absolutely right we'll of course take a
job qualification but we'll do that in
far more detail so we'll try and do that
face face to face we'll try and do that
and meet a few of the team um and and I
guess in in your in your example there
if you were to start working with us we
we'd come down to your office we we'd
get to know you in in in a good amount
of detail we'd obviously make sure you
were comfortable and summarize back
exactly our understanding of the job
from from that point we'd ask for four
to six questions that you typically ask
at first stage interview I'd always
recommend them to be around your mission
vision and values but um equally it
could just be something that you always
ask it could be a fun wacky question
question um that you always ask so that
you can see someone's personality the
reason that we do that is we bring that
into our video interview so we will do a
30 minute screening call with every
candidate that we that we speak to and
we'll do a really targeted search so
kind of open passive and competitive
market
candidates within the first two weeks
that will be mainly kind of in the
background so we'll be doing that we'll
be we'll be generating that long list of
candidates and people that are
interested in working for Hector or or
whoever and do you showcase that to the
Showcase that so we we do a we do a 48
hour up dat um a first week update and
then a middle of second week update with
the goal to get the start of that short
list which is video interviews uploaded
and ready for the client to see the
first two weeks sorry and then is the
update just on a video call we jump on
is it anything visual that you show them
I I I I tend to do at end of the first
week I personally for everyone's
customers will go on and do a video
myself because I want to know exactly
where we are and I want to deliver a Ajo
capture Loom viard what whatever you're
using but to go over exactly the amount
of people that we' reached out to
exactly the amount of people we've
spoken to exactly the amount of people
that are interested and any potential
hurdles obstacles that we found in
getting those candidates to G all that
Fe the kind of virtual hiring table
which in this instance is the first
stage video interview during that video
interview we'll ask four to six
questions um that you've decided that
you want to ask so we're assessing that
candidate against your role and not just
a generic sales marketing or operations
role
um and especially within our kind of our
candidate context I guess sales people
or marketing people anyone commercial
their personality how they carry
themselves how they come across to you
is how they're going to come across or
how they come across to us it's how
they're going to come across to your
customers your internal teams all all
incredibly important stuff so we
packaged that up um on our video short
list alongside the CV um from that point
we we try to get five to eight people um
onto that onto that short list that's
quite a good number I feel that has
enough variety enables people to see a
kind of wide barometer of the market
allows us to get a good amount of
diversity onto that onto that short list
um but but also then then well then they
move forward to a face to face so I
would then obviously I I'm assuming you
like right we've given you the short
list um to give me everything I need and
then I have a Time window to review
those and then do I have to give
feedback
so you give feedback on each person and
we we need and hence why the retained
relationship is there we need feedback
on everyone and we need some decent
feedback on everyone and I'll hold
people to account to to give that
because again if we're it's a customer
experience but it's also the candidate
experience so we we want to make sure
that we're getting as much feedback as
we can from every candidate whether they
are successful not successful from that
point you will typically pick your best
three or four uh to move forward to a
face to face um by that point you kind
of already feel like you know the people
as well because you've seen a good kind
of five 10 minute video of them asking
answering questions that you would
typically ask
um then
finally after that second interview
which so or final interview we run a
cultural assessment so we look at after
the so T typically do that after the
first interview reason being we don't
want to kind of bring in any any bias at
that stage however what we find is the
cultural assessment which is effectively
a all which gives you and maybe we might
get a few of your your sales team to
fill out um 50 questions which give you
your kind of just general preferences um
but then it matches up the candidate who
will do the same against their fit
against the role so a good great or
needs exploring fit against the role but
also good great or needs exploring fit
against your culture and that's just a
direct correlation between the
candidates results and your results so
the candidate fills out as well
candidate fills out as well all three or
four candidates whoever you're bringing
forward to second
interview and the reason we do it at
second interview don't want it to be
that much of a bias in the first
interview but what it does the report
spits out questions that you should ask
in order to explore anything so it's
kind of like that rubber stamp type
questions or the the final little things
that that that we need or we'd advise
you to ask to mitigate as much risk as
we can can as a team through that hiring
hiring process to make sure you're
ultimately hiring not only the best
available candidate but a candidate
who's a match for your business as well
so for the client it's B typically two
stages then so you pretty much do the
first stage for me I just have to invest
the time in watching the um videos and
then give them feedback but then I'm
just spending time with then yeah the
like short short list of face to face
and then there might be one or two
people that don't make it to the second
stage but then in between first and
second stage I'm getting even more uh in
into right what are the things that I
need to make sure I try and um ask this
person and understand that's going to
give me more confidence that they're
going to be a good fit well it we also
do and I don't know if other recruit
agencies do this but not not not many
from from what our customers tell us but
we've we haven't got the biggest sample
size will give areas where even at first
stage the client should explore further
as well and maybe perhaps any
reservations that the candidate might
have any any kind of any reservations
that we might have on the candidate
which again is alien like I always think
and that's what's funny about using some
sort of cultural assessment because it
could come back and say the candidat a
rubbish fit from a cultural perspective
but actually that's still good
because we might we we're always looking
at the longterm the long-term goal and I
always found it funny when especially
Junior recruiters come in they present a
candidate which is typically just a CV
that they pop into someone's inbox and
they say everyone's brilliant but not
everyone's brilliant like there'll be
there'll be areas where everyone's
brilliant I'm brilliant in some areas
I'm also terrible in others so being
able to give a very honest
assessment even if it's not in your best
interest and if you're best interested
just get the fee it's really important
to make sure you're you're presenting
people feel like even even more in the
you'll know better than me but hiring
salese a lot of it typically isn't done
on science-based data tights pieces
right it's a lot of it is off like yeah
I think it's a lot of it is off
intuition and you get along with the
person and those of things so I think I
can imagine that being so
helpful trying to strip that out as much
as you can and also understanding in
exactly the same way um as in
recruitment a great recruiter somewhere
might be a terrible recruitment
somewhere else through lack of kind of
value alignment whatever that looks like
exactly the same within sales someone
might be a great sales person within one
business but terrible with within within
another because perhaps the first
business is more transactional one's
more consultative what whatever that
looks like or they just wouldn't get on
with the team they whatever that is and
actually we would much prefer to
mitigate that risk pre higher than post
higher it's all good and well getting
someone through the door and then after
8 weeks or 12 weeks or six months that
candidate drops out but that's not a
that's not a a great experience for the
for the customer or for the candidate so
actually we'd much rather we'd much
rather experience pain before a decision
is made and make sure all our customers
are thrilled making a hire rather than a
bit of a shot in the dark we'll get back
to the episode in just one minute but
today I wanted to tell you about our
partners sourcewell the industry-leading
business development and head hunting
platform I'm a sourcewell user myself
and it's been an absolute Game Changer
when it comes to crafting personalized
Outreach it's not only quick and easy
but you can tap into custom variables
automate follow-ups and use multiple
channels like the phone LinkedIn EMA
email and more to accelerate results
users report an average increase of 56%
in qualified response rates and when
you're using it it's easy to see why AI
powered tools like content coach and wh
GPT improve your chances of not ending
up in spam something that's become
increasingly challenging with Google's
recent deliverability changes it also
tracks all of your activity into your
CRM keeps your data clean and lets you
know who you need to reach out to and
when so you can spend more time on what
what you're good at recruiting not admin
so if you're serious about being the
best at what you do join me and
thousands of recruiters who have chosen
sourcewell to revolutionize their
Outreach approach book a demo with
sourcewell and mention the recruitment
mentors podcast to enjoy an extra 50
phone and 50 email credits per user and
this exclusive offer will save you Circ
£500 and more and it's only available
until March the 31st click the link in
the episode description or you can head
to source.com
slemo obviously let's talk about the
customer experience and what's besides
getting being more confident that zest
is going to be able to get me the
outcome that I want which is the right
person in the right seat because of this
approach your you've got a great track
record now of yeah really high field
rates um all those types of things but
what is often the feedback you get from
these customers saying around the actual
experience what is it they value the
most is it the video short list cuz it
saves them loads of time like I know it
might vary but what's often ended up
being at the core of like Callum this
service is great because it's a really
good question I think that the one the
one word that sort of shoots to mind is
feedback and feedback from both sides
being able to be brave enough to share
all feedback as quickly as possible um
no matter how good bad or ugly that
feedback is and make sure that people
are fully up to date as as you say like
we've got 100% F rate we will find
really good people but lots of
recruitment agencies can find really
good people can they deliver it in a way
that's exceptional can they deliver it
in a way that truly is creating putting
service at the Forefront and not their
best interest so he I'm going to
introduce this candidate actually I'm
going to pull this person out because
I've got a really bad reference rather
than just waiting and and seeing how it
goes I I don't think many recruitment
agents or or Consultants are brave
enough to do that whereas we are very
focused on the long long-term longterm
um nature of this business long-term
nature of relationships that we'll bu
we're building and I'm very honest in
saying if someone offered me 50 million
possessed now I I wouldn't because
because I want to see out this journey I
genuinely want to change the perception
of Recruitment and anyone on I'm so so
so so so fortunate with the team that
we've got that they share the same the
same vision and the same Val what about
then what about the often what about the
common feedback you get from the on the
candidate side like what is it that you
often hear again um I might if I'm a
candidate I might work with zeston I'm
actually getting in front of the
companies that they talk to me about and
I'm getting interviews like you
delivered the outcomes but what's often
the feedback on that side that you that
again contributes this customer
experience that you often have so so
again feedback was kind of General to
both but
um one thing I will say there is is a
lot of people reservation around using
some sort of video technology is time
and it it delays things but you'd be
surprised how how much feedback we get
that we we're a true extension of our
clients um and how much value the the
video aspect brings it's not it's not a
hindrance in in a lot of Senses it's a
way that a candidate can get their best
self across their best most authentic
self across to the businesses that they
want to be working with and um again one
joy in us not
having a ridiculous amount of customers
and saying no to more customers than we
say yes to is we truly know our we truly
know our customers and uh from from
truly knowing your customers and getting
a really good insight into into
them and and spending time getting to
know your candidates it's much easier to
get the match um well perfect perfect
that kind of match so it's um but but a
lot of it is around the feedback again
that that plus 89 MPS score is something
that we're incredibly proud of 77% of
that is from candidates who didn't get a
job so 77 77% of that NPS score is and
would you mind just in really brief
terms explaining that if you're happy to
um like cuz not everyone might know
obvious we use that in our in our
business but not everyone is aware of
what that is it from my understanding it
literally is the sort of um the best way
or the most used way to measure customer
experience promot score and and
experience generally it could be
employee experience net Pro promoter
score is effectively How likely you are
to recommend zest to a friend or
colleague um and they will get a survey
after being in a process through our our
business um and they will get a survey
that says How likely are you to
recommend zest to a friend or colleague
it will say a 1 to 10 score a nine or 10
will be a promoter
um I think it's a seven or passive
so yeah so
um so we we we do that as I say so 77%
of the respondes for for our MPS
scores who didn't get a job people who
didn't get a job people have been in a
process who got got told told they were
a no who dropped out whatever that looks
like and um still that's that's
something that like yeah I think I had I
think I might mention to you but I had
Abby done on the podcast who's also like
really committed to his customer
experience which I absolutely love and
her sort of gripe uh with it with what
she's seen like outwardly of other
companies was often times you'll see
people give that net promoter score
option only once they placed in the job
right and that's what I think and she
was saying well actually the ones that I
really care about and when we get low
scores are the ones from people that
didn't get the job cuz that's I feel
like their the experiences you really
want to improve um improve so I love
that stat on 77 % of your Net promoe
score has been um yeah given by people
that didn't get a job which is not the
outcome that they wanted right but
because of the service that you built
and your commitment to it um you're
still delivering great experience and
why I think that's so overlooked we've
done a couple of training sessions on
this and I always remember one I don't
know if you got any stories like this
but um we had a guy called Rich uh how
who recruits an fmcg and he's really big
on this and he was saying one of his
biggest clients came from sumone that he
didn't place and he really focused on
the experience of people that didn't get
the job and making sure that's covered
right so again these are often people
that get forgotten about or it's just
easier it's it's more comfortable to not
give them the bad news and do all the
things that we've all done um but
actually there some of the the can be
some of your best promoters that end up
in some of your best clients potentially
happens all the time happens all the
time especially like sales leadership
give give someone a good experience the
there's so many people that get placed
who have a terrible recruitment
experience or just don't don't know
don't don't know who their recruiter was
don't know who what agency represented
them it was a very transactional
experience and again that's that's why
it's adding value through the process
but I'm
um I I completely agree there's so many
recruitment agencies who will only sort
of survey people that they've given a
positive outcome to and actually not
only does that skew figures but it's
it's not particularly useful because why
are you asking for feedback and I'll
never I'll never um sort of not be
Greatful for our NPS score but in some
ways I'm hoping this year it's slightly
lower because I want to get I I want to
get more feedback to improve that that's
that's why we're doing it and it's
bloody brilliant that we deliver a a
phenomenal experience and and that will
always be the core of our business and
what we what we Endeavor to do every
single time but um we're doing it so so
we can get feedback ultimate ultimately
to improve and we've already had three
customers three candidates this year got
a job for another recruiter but gave us
a review didn't even ask them to do this
but gave us the review and it said in
the review Callum or Aaron or Adam or
Lizzy didn't Place me but they were far
better than the agency that did and what
a brilliant way that's great to send to
the company that person's joined yeah
yeah their new starter has said we're a
better fit or we're better we gave a
better experience than the person that
placed them
what what a brilliant what a brilliant
um in and what a brilliant kind of bit
of feedback to to receive let me ask you
this then with your commitment to this
and I think this is at the center of
what we do we've broken down your
service and this results in so many
positive things right in terms of like
we're talking about your team they know
the roles that they work on they place
they know the companies and customers
they partner with are companies that are
a good fit and fit your ICP and um they
know hopefully they're going to get the
commitment that they need so this just
benefits everything right it's just
pretty mad that a lot of companies don't
make this commitment but I think this is
why I want to ask you this which is if
you think about this second year you've
really committed to this you are so
close to everyone because it's a small
team what are some of the things that
you could be uh what's the
word the analogy that I want to give is
like there could be some things that
happen that make Callum go oh yeah we
could earn some good money there and it
makes you drop some of these standards
the things that you have to resist you
know what I mean what are some of the
things that you know you're going to
have to fight really hard to come back
to this cuz that that happens right cuz
I'm sure at this stage you're just so
involved in everything but what are some
of those things that you know you're
going to have to not be enticed by that
could lead to getting away from this
yeah I think it's um it's a good
question um and you mentioned money is
the obvious one so money or any sort of
Revenue or profit or whatever whatever
that looks like however luckily our
biggest driver isn't money um genuinely
we're we're I'm a big believer that
um if you're very true to what you do
profit will always come I I I've and and
I've never not from an arrogant sense
I've never had to worry about money
through through work working or doing
what I do because I've learned and it's
a learn Behavior now if I try and add
zest or add value through every
conversation the right things will come
so I I I think I think the the there
maybe a different way to frame the
question or answer the question is
something that I'm very conscious of is
making sure that every hire that we hire
is truly value that's probably one of
the biggest ways to keep it exactly
people have got to have the same beliefs
as I will and there'll be so many people
that have been on your podcast listen to
your podcast who have different views
for me around than me around money or or
or or whatever whatever that looks like
we we measure our success truly number
one number one promise of that is the
experience that our customers and
candidates have um and we will always be
very true to that and our belief is if
we continue to live deliver against that
and to to continue to deliver against
our our model and what we do money will
everything will take care of and it's
quite hard to say as well by the way
just quickly on that the contingent side
so if someone came to me now and said
look Callum we can give you 500k worth
of business that's
contingent there's elements of that
would be
tempting but what I can't do to that
business is tell them what we'll deliver
because everything that we've done is
delivering against the model that we'll
we we'll deliver against the model that
we'll operate and I can't and I'm
certainly not going to start doing the
same search for someone that doesn't pay
a third up front cuz then that isn't
fair to the customer customers that do
partner with us and work with us the way
they they do so it's got to be
consistent and I've got to know that
whatever we're signing ourselves up for
we're going to have to be we're going to
be able to deliver against because that
is our key kind of promiser of success
yeah to be fair I think yeah you are
probably right the fundamental way to
really protect that and really have that
embedded in your business as you grow is
going to be the people that you hire cuz
you can probably very easily point at a
client and say this is why should have
said no to this client so moving forward
if they have any of these
characteristics we need to make sure we
say no and this is why that's probably a
lot more easier rather than trying to
convert someone that's in your business
convert their behaviors and mindset
towards what good a good experience
looks like right so yeah I was just just
curious a good it's a good it's a good
question it's interesting right but I
think what we've also done which I
really R and again this is the the
really great thing about having your own
business is you can do these ideas that
you've had and you can take action on
things that maybe you've always thought
about could we try this could we do this
better but you also again I don't know
how many companies do this but you also
it's that important that you're you're
also providing a financial incentive on
your team um to your team on The NPS
score as well yeah so I want to talk a
bit about that cuz I don't think you
know you'll hear Commission on what you
build and these things but your team
also are financially incentivized to
deliver a great experience which I think
is really cool as well yeah and no know
I appreciate you bringing that and it's
um it's something I want to stress as
well that that that we still need to
incentivize consultants and and our
teams based off delivering and numbers
as well because
that you you you can you can deliver a
phenomenal experience when place out no
one and ultimately you won't have a job
in recruitment for very long but um
you're you're absolutely right so we we
pay monthly based off of an individual's
Billings in a very similar way to any
other recruitment agency will will will
do but then quarterly we pay a extra
kicker based off of delivering
phenomenal experiences and that is
delivering a certain number of promoters
within that period So within a three
Monon
period and we we've said it at the
moment as a as a really manageable and
we've uh I think a few of the guys have
got over 15 and what is the 12th of Jan
or whatever so it's incredibly
manageable manageable number um and we
give 5% of their quarterly um number as
a bonus in addition to their commission
so that so typically for a senior
consultant that will be over 10 grand a
year just for delivering phenomenal
experiences yeah that's I'm around that
well it's it's h again it's a great
initiative to have that's the cool thing
about having your own business that you
can do these things yeah but also if if
we're going to drive the um the right
behaviors if we're going to change the
perception of Recruitment and truly do
that we need to incentivize it be that
yeah the game has to be incentivized in
that way exactly exactly and um yeah
it's worked really well so far and it
you can tell from the results that we've
that we've had and how passionate each
and everyone within the zest team are at
the end of a week looking back and just
having such lovely bits of feedback come
through MH it's it's just it's just the
it's the same kick that you get from
doing a deal it's uh it's phenomen we've
spoken a lot about how the benefit
commercially to your business uh the The
Fill rates the the experience you're
given to candidates clients and how this
can actually help your business grow
just like
commercially but how have you found as
You' started to grow this business like
how when you've spoken about this
approach like how have you found it
impact actually your in ability to hire
people or attract people because I think
that's always going to be one of your
challenges like everyone is aware of
particularly a recruitment agency in
London it's just so competitive but have
you also found that when you do get in
front of the right person uh from
internal High standpoint this is
something that also gives you
competitive advantage in that
conversation gives us competitive
advantage to the right person yeah
there's a lot of recruiters that I
wouldn't have exactly the same to the
way that we'll say no to a lot of a lot
of business we'll say no to a lot of
recruiters and a lot of really
successful recruiters and actually
recruiters that I would respect a lot
they're just not right for us so it's
it's understanding what good looks like
to our business and it's um making sure
that we're shouting about that enough we
incentivizing the right thing we're
driving the right behaviors um driving
the right activities and absolutely and
again I think we're we're all quite
lucky and we we try to to really I've
always been a big advocate of the kind
of personal brand and making sure we're
sharing on LinkedIn but I put out a
video both times I've I've put out a
video saying we're hiring and we've got
quite an unusual benefits package um but
we've been flooded with uh flooded with
applicants and and really experienced
applicants um how do you test people's
commitment to that experience I I always
I always it's it's quite easy to see um
I I think and there'll be lots of people
that say they deliver a great experience
but some someone like Lizzy for example
who is Bloody brilliant who joined um in
November that that's the thing that she
was proud of the the testimony that she
had from her previous
customers um and that to me is just like
a an absolute um dingding ding kind of
gold gold mine of a of a of a zest
employee someone who puts customer
experience over everything um and and
equally H as well they have to have the
capability they have to be good at the
job um but you can see and that's that's
the best thing about experience that's
the best thing about tracking feedback
and even if someone doesn't have a like
um a formal feedback tracking system in
place which a lot of recruitment
agencies won't there's a whole host of
things around like LinkedIn
recommendations um emails that people
will save and and kind of hold close
their heart from someone just saying
look Callum did a phenomenal job Lizzie
did a phenomenal job for this that and
the other reason and um yeah we we've we
we've been really there's only five for
us so far we're going to grow far more
aggressively this year but every time
that we posted about hiring um I know
it's very competitive but we've had
quite a lot of people is that is that
one of the cuz that was one of my
questions I feel like for a for quite a
while now you've done I feel like a good
job of building your own brand and that
then you really see that come into
fruition when you start your own
business cuz it's like wow I can you
know do this activity online and I can
see the direct benefit like when you
first started and then got your first
client right um it just feels a bit
different compared to when you're an
employee I feel like you know what I
mean like you literally see the direct
impact of you sharing something building
your brand and then it impacting your
business but is that one of the big
impacts youve found it to have in terms
of building your brand because you have
done you guys have invested a lot in
your marketing on the marketing side as
well yeah no I think it's um there's
there's two things there there's there's
there's two sides of that question
there's number one for me I'm not
wearing anyone else's Cape I'm not
wearing anyone I'm not representing
anyone else's brand I can truly be my
authentic self um which is one of our
values be yourself
always and you don't feel like oh maybe
that won't align with what my company's
doing or or or whatever and
I'm so far from what I would Define The
Stereotype of a recruiter as well but I
I can truly and honestly be myself and I
think it stands out and my the feedback
that we get is that that kind of stands
out in terms of the service in terms of
the added value in terms of what we try
and deliver to the market the second
side of that question is starting a
business completely aresh you can also
make sure that you hire people who are
value aligned and who know exactly what
they're coming into and don't feel like
they're wearing a cape
feel like they're truly representing a
business that's an extension of
themselves feel like they're truly
representing a business where they can
be themselves and authentically
themselves every day and they're so
proud to shout about that and then it's
much easier to go on that kind of
personal branding Journey there some
Adam who I've worked with for years and
is phenomenal at the job never really
posted never really shared anything
until this year and now he posts more
than me and he get he's got such a
community of followers and and people
that he didn't have before but he's he's
able to and not necessarily he couldn't
do that before but he can it's
completely strip back and it's
completely authentic to him and toest as
as the brand and the culture kind of
defines itself in these early years as
well so there's kind of two sides to
that but yeah it feels kind of more free
posting and it certainly helped us build
our brand and and build our following
opportunities and stuff we'll get back
to the episode in just one minute but
today I'm excited to talk to you about
one of our partners Firefish the
recruitment CRM that accelerates data
driven growth they have just released
their 2024 recruitment agency report
based on insights from over 200 agency
leaders the report offers unbelievable
insights into forecasts for the year
ahead enabling you to refine your
strategy Based on data rather than
intuition here are some of the stats I
personally found interesting from the
report although industry optimism has
declined for the third in a row growth
signals remain positive with 84% of
agency leaders expecting year-on-year
sales growth this year 47% of agency
leaders plan to use a contingency
recruitment model in 2024 and 70% of
agencies plan to use social sourcing as
their main candidate attraction strategy
in 2024 you can access your free copy of
the report and start making data driven
decisions about your business by
clicking the link in the the show notes
and whilst you're there if you wanted to
check out how Firefish could help your
business grow this year they very kindly
offered a unique offer to our community
the recruitment mentors podcast that's
going to save you up to £1,000 and this
offer is only available until March the
31st you can click the link in the
episode description and you can also
head to Firefish software.com
slrm just curious then how you think
about you said there you want to really
continue to grow and SC
what's coming to mind is again at the
center of all of this is the customer
experience how do you think about when
you're scaling like is there how do I
say this not I don't use the word like
ceiling or like things are C but I'd
love to just hear your perspective of if
you keep bringing in these recruiters
that are aligned their
experienced obviously what's going to be
really important is uh they deliver your
service and uh you know stay true to
that but I feel like you tell me you
might disagree but I feel like if I'm
someone joining your business surely
there must be a cap of the amount of
customers I can support in order for me
to maintain those levels of
service yeah I might be wrong there but
I don't know if you've thought about
that like so like if I join your
business do you think you know unless
you start building a team around me and
help me support that way in order for me
to really maintain those levels it's
going to be hard for me to serve 15
customers on on my own maybe I don't
know what the number is but
but but the good thing is that I'm I
know I'm getting paid on the jobs that I
work and these things so I don't know if
you thought about that do you feel like
there's maybe uh a limit until you have
to start building people around them
they can there certainly will be and I
think it's really important I certainly
think until we're kind of 10 plus so
certainly double digits we can was been
proven with the kind of interest that
we've had that we can hire experienced
people and ultimately they can develop
their own relationships and there's
there's so many there's so much
opportunity within the market there's
there's always there's plenty of
business to go around there's plenty of
opportunity but I I do and my track
record and why I feel in a really
fortunate position to do this we we the
the guys who work with me today um three
of three of them I hired into
recruitment in their first job so I we
have been on that kind of trainy Journey
themselves we've I've LED them through
that experience they've LED plenty of
trainees themselves through that
experience so can absolutely do that and
there there definitely is a kind of
there's there's the the support and
infrastructure that a really successful
recruiter needs when they're delivering
x amount of X number or with x amount of
sort of customers where they need
additional human sort of support um and
that would be a really nice experience
not only for the the the kind of senior
members of our team to have that support
and infrastructure around them but also
for people coming into our business when
the brand and the the identity and our
customer experience and how we operate
op is so clearly defined and it's not
just me and now me plus four people it's
an army of people delivering this very
clearly defined
authentic differentiated service and
through osmosis those people will
eventually kind of grow into the senior
recruiters of the future and we've
absolutely been on a journey before
where we've we've tro on that path so
it'll be something long term that we we
we need to be mindful of but for the
time being there's plenty of
opportunities there yeah how many like
I'm just curious thinking about it like
how many how many customers do you
reckon a perm recruiter could serve and
work with do a really good job on in 12
months and what do you think they could
build do you think it's a good question
things we spoken about you know what I
mean it's a good question I think
um there's a lot of variables but I feel
like there might you might have a bit of
an idea of to to to to to do it really
well and you you've got to look at it's
probably best looking at roles and
rather than customers in some senses
because
how many R well well
so my my goal is one one placement a
week um which looks at and I think in in
a good Market you can absolutely do that
um if the demand is there and then
that's 600k is Billings um which is a
decent perm number um whilst maintaining
all those custom experience levels yeah
and and I I think you then have to you
then have to do the the kind of call the
backward reverse engineering of like how
many but probably about 10 customers I
would say about 10 customers that are
properly qualified that are long-term
partners that we can truly be impactful
within and stamp our Mark within and be
an extension of their business I think
someone could do that's exciting that
isn't it it doesn't that's that's not a
lot yeah that that that's another thing
about recruitment I uh people you think
is everyone's so focused on like
activity and and and on boarding 10 new
customers a week and doing actually
we've done over 500k had 25 customers
it's been a really and of course we'll
do far more than that and and we we'll
grow and we'll we'll we'll develop more
relationships and do do more and may be
be more impactful but that that I know
all 25 I've met all 25 multiple times
this year it's been a really enjoyable
experience we've genuinely impacted all
those businesses all of those businesses
will come back as soon as they're hiring
and um so cut that in half one person
can absolutely do that and there's some
big numbers to to be to be made for for
the people that that do and that's why I
think that's really exciting the way
they've approached it just cuz yeah like
you can be really highper I think that
like what I really like about what
you're doing
is you're
not like you the way that you view it is
you can be high performing and you can
deliver an exceptional service do you
know what I mean I just really like
thinking from that mindset of like how
can you do both um do you know what I
mean how can you yeah how can you be
really high performing and deliver an
absolutely exceptional service and I
think that's just a really good way to
look at how you can build this business
because it it can absolutely be both
rather than how can we just get people
generate as much revenue as possible and
okay if we miss the mark a few times and
we you know burn a few Bridges along the
way then it doesn't really matter cuz
we're really high performing but you're
really trying to drive let's let's be as
high performing as possible and let's
yeah have the customer experience at the
center of everything that we do and how
can we do both it's a terrible term but
it's work smarter not harder and
actually something the biggest thing
that I I still work harder than nearly
anyone but the it's making sure that
there's so much wasted time there's so
much busy fooling done in recruitment
where people take on all this contingent
work run around like a headless chicken
yeah I've got 10 rolls to work I've got
50 customers
no you don't sit down give me your
pipeline and I could break down which
roles you'll actually fill Focus your
time on them and actually be brave
enough to say to the other companies
this probably isn't for us but it would
be for us if this that or the other
reason and I think you can absolutely do
both I I can absolutely prove that um
and the way I would view a zest or my
myself someone someone would beat me in
recruitment give give them six months
and we do a six-month race give it two
years I think anyone with zest would
smash anyone out the park because we're
genuinely going to be focused on how
many people that business is going to
hire over two years and how can we
maximize the value that we can serve
that customer with over that period so
that they don't want to go anywhere else
and there's no need for them to go
anywhere else yeah I love that and um
that's why I think yeah like I really
respect the respect the journey you've
being on cuz I feel like you're even
just listening back to our conversation
three years ago like all of this is like
was ringing true for you then and now
you're in an environment where you're
building this business around all these
things that you've cared about for a
long time and I just really love how
much you're championing this message of
like we're just talking about doing
Absolut you can to build a worldclass
experience whilst you're doing that
changing and really moving the needle on
changing the perception of uh our
industry and whilst you're doing all
these great things you can also be
really high performing and absolutely
why can't you build a recruitment
business around those values and princi
principles and be really high performing
and offer a great environment for
recruiters to Excel and Advance their
career without maybe sometimes going
home and being like not sure I delivered
a good service today you yeah yeah and I
think um I think what can often be
overlooked and as I said at the start of
the conversation our vision is radically
changed the perception of how a
recruitment agency serves its people
customers and communities and people is
first so our team will always come first
and I think that is not only my focus
but everyone's Focus we'll deliver
phenomenal experience to our candid
candidates and customers but it's making
sure we deliver phenomenal experiences
to people internally as well and kind of
our ethos our benefits package how how
we look to incentivize people as we've
kind of touched upon there um or earlier
I think that's incredibly important and
I I think I said you the other week I
was interested that a lot of people I
know went to interview at lots of
different recruitment companies and
still came back to me wanting to work
for us M and I was interested in that I
was thinking why is there no one where
people is just really interested really
wanting to work for that business so I
think I want to be the Willy Wonker of
recruitment I I want to create a
business that is truly the best place to
work the best place and and that isn't
just by paying people more no that's by
number one The Human Side being on that
Journey growing lots of people's careers
development plans but then giving them
the internal benefits and support they
need in infrastructure tools everything
they need to to thrive and then also
from an external perspective we give 750
c a year for people to travel well-being
allowance private medical um well
well-being days we gave five figures
this year to charity or last year to
charity and to have a couple of
volunteering days like they just just
truly be the best place to work in
recruitment where someone can actually
see a long term career path within this
industry um is really important to me so
that's where the experience side as well
well let's let's see where this uh if if
Canon can become the the Woodly
W it's a big it's a big uh it's a big
claim and a random and I love it but no
look honestly it can really mean it when
I say yeah kudos to you and what you're
building and I just really just yeah
really like this framing of um I had
Andrew on the other day Andrew S turn he
he spoke about this and it is about you
know you can have people really engaged
and high performing and that's what I
really like about you were saying
everything you're talking about it isn't
just all in that direction of great
place to work paid really well all these
types of things it's also but you're
also going to be environment where going
to be pushed out your comfort zone
you're going to be performing as best as
you can and the standards are going to
be really high so it's about yeah
pushing the boundaries of both of those
being really engaged and high performing
and I think that's exactly what you're
build add some on excited to see where
we end up in another year two years it's
uh it's interesting you say that and
I'll just leave with one final thing in
regards to I don't know if people can
have football fans but that's how I view
putting a team together and you see all
these teams who just spend all this
money on the best players but there's no
identity there they don't know who
they're joining like a man united or you
got so many players but there's no
identity to the business and that's how
I view putting a team together and I
think it's really important to
understand that you can be incredibly
High
performing but also deliver a phenomenal
experience and and sports is a great
example of how I view that kind of team
team an allergy the everyone fighting
for their position every year but
everyone being truly the best per placed
person with within within that team
rather than it kind of being just
somewhere where yeah someone comes works
and that that that's fine there's got to
be the capability there's got to be the
high standards there and you can
absolutely deliver a phenomenal
experience and have both get get paid
very well and have a long-term career
and recruitment where you earn well over
six figures
and bloody enjoy what you do and feel
really impactful in what you do and
that's our goal love it thanks for Jo me
the thank you